The done.
Thankfully he was into the rice shit.
But I would see him go on stage and I would see his humility.
He wouldn't,
he would always say Java is the ability of anything that I have.
He would always give praises to the most high to Jah.
Rastafari.
Humble is fucking hell and the best musicians to ever,
those four motherfuckers are praised by every single fuck.
The musician today,
if you talk doc,
Daryl,
Earl and Gary doctor know every motherfucking musician out there will be like
those dudes are the fucking dance cause they study music.
They were into jazz and they were into fucking return to forever.
And John McLaughlin Mahavishnu doc in 81 was like they call me squids cause they
met me in an Ey.
Yo squids,
I want to take you to the palladium returned to fair.
One of the coaches quit cause I was that they met me in the navy.
Oh squids.
Like a squid.
You'll squids.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
And then uh,
and then they call me Johnny Joe.
So that's where the John Joseph,
I didn't use my last name cause I was foregoing a future.
If for 15 years.
Oh,
that's funny.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
the,
the thing was he's,
you know,
returned to forever is owl Demille,
Ola,
Lenny white,
Stanley Clarke.
And I'm missing chicory.
Fucking do you ever listen to this shit?
So you want to go down a motherfucker?
No.
Listen,
to return to forever romantic word.
You want to go down a rabbit hole?
We'd,
how fucking amazing these fucking musicians are,
or weather report where any of these,
you know,
Maha Vishnu,
birds of fire.
Like they started turning me and he was say,
squids,
this is how we learn to play with the fuck we play.
And nobody could touch the bad brains musically,
energy on stage,
nothing.
And I would see these dudes,
I'd be like,
what the fuck are you into?
And then the role models that,
like you said,
it,
you know,
we need good role models.
There's,
there's,
you know,
there's so many fucked up people that,
uh,
these kids want to emulate today.
You know,
and I see it cause I came up in New York,
I worked in all the underground hip hop clubs.
I work for the pope a pot.
I used to deliver pot to all the rap stars.
I delivered pot pot.
My friend,
uh,
does to Matt Work for Tristar.
He's like,
Yo,
meet me at the Boston Comedy Club.
There's this black comedian there and he's going to be fucking huge.
And I would show up on my bike.
And you know who you know,
who the fuck it was?
Dave Chappelle.
They fuck Chapelle they focus your pell.
And when he did half bake,
did you notice that he put the weed delivery guy in all bike gear?
We'll fuck you think you got that phone.
I used to show up.
I never carried a bag.
I showed up with a $4,000 carbon fiber carbon fiber frame and I had a black
water bottle and all the weed bags was in the two water bottles.
So it just looked like I was a cyclist out on a motherfucking out on a ride.
Oh Wow.
Hell yeah.
And then they,
uh,
Dave Chappelle,
we didn't,
he blew up.
So fairs,
Mannheim was the guy's name.
He was the publicist there at Tristar pitches.
And then I delivered to him at the Boston comedy club and we didn't,
like months,
he was living in some police show fucking spot on like second avenue and 15th in
the,
and I might go,
how the fuck did you get from an area he ate?
He just.